hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master l mom L marmalade it's a
mammogram off let's see what he plays
against this he just takes it okay he
has a knack for fishy lines usually a
little bit and didn't expect him to play
the absolute main line but he's let's
see what happens yeah this is possible
early five I think black is okay with
this but it leads to murky situations we
just right up his alley of course let's
see e six now is so interesting I bet
the bishop would hang so probably not
that great so okay how to play here um
Queen B six maybe yeah let's get this
tempo on the beep on really
always see form hmm let's do it like
that it's interesting for Bishop f5
later you know maybe he can take d6 NC
for Bishop f5 and then play with the
pawns second sacrifice something then
interesting in any way let's seem very
very murky position so knight c6 so it
takes on c4 hmm of course you can move
the rook that that's that's true of
course oh I'll take be true then
night c60 actually now i'm thinking you
might immediately threaten something on
this expect of the case so let's see
what you body place in this one okay
giving the exchange like that that was
definitely an option so okay now i can
take c 3 and then be one or just be one
immediately I think I'll take be one
here and now hmm so couple of things
Queen before is also interesting
attacking the bishop asking him know if
the bishop moves actually pick up this
Bishop there so what does this move
against screen before I lose pieces jump
off I think this is a piece right what
does he have some to some trick up its
sleeve that picks up one of those
bishops I think
you also cannot Kobe 3 SC 3 is hanging
white reason yeah I just say drops a
piece it's just what it is yeah the
bangko is an active opening and
sometimes you can can really am and win
quick games like that so what's that
seem I think this is probably
theoretically a well-known I'm not sure
about this year may I guess that this is
probably the best move like just taking
this and play for the usual compensation
that that he definitely has and this is
maybe this is a bit too ambitious iron
on the computer gives Bishop b5 hmm yeah
that makes some sense of course the idea
is that is getting rid of my strong
bishop on g7 and here why this better
yeah okay that was the problem with my
idea he went with this however and now
at least things are very very murky yeah
okay this this doesn't seem to work all
that well this is interesting Ella
mentioned during the during the game I
think I probably don't take now here
this is looking strange computer gives
this year that's fascinating
you
I'm a root gap right but I have no way
to save a piece funny and white is
actually better here okay it's got pawns
d6 hangs me interesting and here yes to
teague with the night which is still
okay and this is this blondeness run
this apiece essentially this is really
loose pieces top off is one of those
funky sentences that really are true if
you have many pieces unprotected there
is a tactic usually just around the
corner and this is one of those cases ok
guys thanks for watching